pré site internet réunion pour la
première point fr vous écoutez la
première il est 18 heures
[Musique]
le journal présenté préparé par florent
marot bonsoir bonsoir redit bonsoir à
tous
une mesure inacceptable selon ericka
bareitgs l'impôt sur le revenu pourrait
augmenter pour les réunionnais les plus
aisés le livre bleu outremer prévoit en
effet la suppression des 30 %
d'abattement d'hommes pour les plus
riches à ce qui fait grincer des dents
au sein même des partisans de la
majorité
réactions à suivre on connaîtra demain
la date du début de la campagne sucrière
mais c'est imminent les cachalots et
leur chargement de cannes seront bientôt
sur les routes
les usiniers attendent les résultats des
derniers tests
la dengue l'épidémie continue de sévir
dans l'ouest et le sud on en est à près
de 400 cas chaque semaine mais les des
appareils sont en vente pour capturer et
tuer les moustiques comment ça marche
réponse dans un instant en sport on
parlera du mondial de foot évidemment
brésil mexique vient de démarrer mais
aussi de karaté avant lundi politique à
18h15 ce soir à gaël dantec reçoit jean
pierre marchau secrétaire régional
d'europe écologie les verts
mais d'abord direction la ravine creuse
à s'attendre et où un forcené s'est
retranché chez lui cet après midi
l'homme armé a pu être ramené à la
raison grâce à l'intervention du gipn et
tout est allé très vite
olivier delarichaudy oui arrivé sur site
rue des badamiers si ravine creuse un
peu avant 17h la quinzaine d'hommes du
groupe d'intervention de la police
nationale peut extraire l'homme du
domicile familial en une dizaine de
minutes
le forcené retenait en otage sa propre
mère sous la menace d'une arme à feu
selon le commandant de police bertrand
dubuc l'homme n'a opposé aucune
résistance lors de son interpellation il
a été placé en garde à vue au
commissariat de saint-andré où il
devrait à recevoir la visite d'un
médecin rapidement
aucune information pour l'instant sur
les motivations du forcené
des investigations seront menées pour
déterminer c'est l'individu fait état
d'éventuels antécédents psychologiques
et psychiatriques par olivier
delarichaudy en direct de ravine creuse
à saint-andré c'est une niche qui existe
depuis près de soixante ans les 30 %
d'abattement d'hommes pourraient
prochainement être supprimé pour les
foyers les plus aisés la mesure est
inscrite dans le livre bleu outremer
présenté la semaine dernière à l'elysée
alors question les impôts sur leurs
revenus vont ils augmenter pour à ces
réunionnais les plus riches
l'objectif en tout cas est d'économiser
400 millions d'euros à la réunion entre
10 et 20% des ménages pourraient être
concernés à ce qui fait grincer des
dents je vous le disais au sein même des
partisans de la majorité
les précisions de daniel pouny
responsable du comité local la bretagne
en marche
ce n'est pas une bonne chose parce que
si vous supprimez 30% du revenu de
quelqu'un ce même quelqu'un ira moins
consommer ce même quelqu'un ira moins
faire travailler des gens sur des
aménagements de sa maison que 16 autres
à moins de voitures et aux et moi je dis
que heureusement que à l'heure où on
parle c'est un projet qui est inscrit
dans le livre bleu mais j'imagine que
mac on ne va pas aller donner
satisfaction à ce grave et c'est un
moyen de créer le débat de faire un peu
le buzz parce que
l'abattement fiscal en outre-mer c'est
plus que les 30 % c'est vraiment toute
la société qui va être mis à mal si on
venait à supprimer cet avantage fiscal
un daniel pouny responsable du comité
local la bretagne en marche interrogé
par olivier delarichaudy autre réaction
celle d'eric à barrett qui parle de
régression inacceptable selon la députée
le gouvernement se trompe sur la forme
et sur le fond elle affirme qu'elle
avait en tant que ministre des outre-mer
refusé cette proposition de victorin
lurel à cette mesure est inacceptable
conclure et cabaret jazz qui a décidé de
se mobiliser
le livre bleu qui parle aussi d'un
circuit flambant neuf pour 2021 à la
réunion le projet de la ligue régionale
de sport automobile et de l'association
jacques 9 7 4 a été retenue il pourrait
proposer aux amateurs de conduite
sportive tout le nécessaire à slalom
poursuite et surtout sprint c'est grâce
à une ligne droite d'un kilomètre
ainsi pour l'instant le site n'a pas été
dévoilé les porteurs de projet insistent
déjà sur le modèle économique ce circuit
doit être considéré comme un outil de
service public
yanis c'est l'ail et le président de
l'association jacques 9 7 4
c'est comme stade de foot stade
d'athlétisme un terrain de basket un
skatepark j'ai dit c'est pas que ça soit
rentable c'est pas de générer des
bénéfices sur le dos des passionnés
c'est pour ça qu'on pense que il faut
absolument trouver une forme économique
on puisse réduire les coûts et proposer
un accès si possible gratuit ou en tout
cas à des prix extrêmement bas pour que
tous les passionnés puissent glisser sur
le circuit on pourra obtenir je pense
80% des passionnés sur circuit
sous cette condition pourquoi payer 5
euros pour aller regarder un run alors
que on peut aller regarder la pousse
gratuitement et en famille voyez
pourquoi pays des engagements à 50 euros
payés des licences si c'est juste
seulement pour 200 m yanis c'est l'aï
président de l'association jacques 9,7
re4 interrogé par olivier delarichaudy
est ce un circuit devrait coûter au
moins 5 millions d'euros a priori
majoritairement financée par l'état un
circuit qui pourrait voir le jour dans
le sud ou dans l'ouest
pas de limitation de vitesse sur un
circuit mais il y en a sur la route
depuis hier les portions à 90 elles sont
passées à 80 km/heure à la réunion cela
concerne est la route des plages ou
encore la route de sainte rose
les forces de l'ordre avaient prévu
d'effectuer des contrôles aujourd'hui
mais sans pv le montant de l'amendé qui
sera ensuite de 68 euros avec un point
en moins sur le permis
la première 18h06 on parlait de la route
florent et bien il va bientôt falloir
composer avec les cachalots ni les
cachalots et leur chargement de cannes
seront bientôt sur les routes
on connaîtra demain soir la date du
début de la campagne sucrière le comité
mixte du sinn a prévu de se réunir en
fin d'après midi
mais en fait tout dépendra du résultat
des tests qui ont démarré ce matin à
l'usiné de bois rouge des tests
importants car les machines ont été
démontées pour être nettoyée aujourd'hui
il s'agit de voir si tous les éléments
ont bien été remontées qu'il fonctionne
avec les nouveaux appareils acquis par
l'usinier florent thibault et le
directeur agricole de tereos on n'attend
pas des 3000 pieds pour tout fonctionne
bien on fait avant le décollage
exactement ce qui s'est passé ce matin
les line a commencé a réceptionné à
quelques tonnages pour les essais autour
de 1000 tonnes mais elle va commencer
son process industriel pour vérifier que
chacun des éléments du process
fonctionne correctement
cette année l'usiné réalisé à peu près 4
millions d'euros d'investissements et
donc ses 4 millions d'euros notamment
dans des malaxeurs par exemple il faut
vérifier que les avertissements
fonctionne correctement il
ils ont été correctement installé au
début de tereos est à chaque fois tu
avais sur les sucreries pour conserver
les niveaux d'excellence mondiaux qui
sont nécessaires pour les process la
florent thibault directeur agricole de
tereos joint par johanna d'amadora si la
en revanche c'est sûr ce ne sera pas
avant jeudi les paillotes de l'ermitage
n'ont pas l'intention de fermer avant le
5 juillet date de l'examen par le
tribunal administratif de leur recours
contre l'état et la mairie de saint-paul
ses restaurants de plage n'ont plus
l'autorisation d'occupation temporaire
depuis hier et la préfecture a fait
constater l'infraction par les agents de
la dea al les paillotes il en sera
encore question ce soir dans l'indie
politique gaël le dantec reçoit jean
pierre marche
le secrétaire régional d'europe écologie
les verts conseiller municipal de saint
denis et vice président de la cinor en
charge des déplacements rendez vous
juste après ce journal autre chiffre 400
on en est à près de 400 cas de dengue
par semaine à la réunion l'épidémie
elle sévit toujours dans le sud et
l'ouest la rs demande la participation
de tous les réunionnais maître du
répulsif évitez l'eau stagnante à
l'etang-salé un habitant veut aller plus
loin et propose trois appareils
révolutionnaires le principe imiter une
respiration humaine par la diffusion de
dioxyde de carbone et de phéromones le
moustique est alors à tirer avant d'être
aspiré par un ventilateur est ce
efficace
l' agence régionale de santé ne veux pas
faire de commentaires
boris dumas coordinateur de la lutte
anti vectorielle alors vis-à-vis des
moyens de protection il y en a plusieurs
il n'y a pas une solution miracle on va
dire mais c'est un panel d'options qui
sont les bienvenus et toutes les actions
sont bonnes à prendre
effectivement les répulsifs sont le
moyen le plus efficace mais il n'ya pas
que les répulsifs également tout un
panel d'actions chacun choisira le sien
où les siens il existe en effet
plusieurs dispositifs soient de piégeage
de moustiques soit de répulsifs ou
autres certains sont clairement
inefficaces comme par exemple les
ultrasons ou autre d'autres peuvent être
efficaces mais c'est à chacun d'en faire
l'essai d'autre part nous faisons pas la
promotion de cet art dispositif qui se
développe mais chacun libre d'utiliser
le dispositif qu'il souhaite et s'il est
efficace à boris dumas coordinateur de
la lutte anti vectorielle la rs
interrogé à parra pierre comorassamy
dans l'hexagone le nom et la photo de
redoine faïd ont été transmis aux
policiers gendarmes du pays le braqueur
condamné à 25 ans de prison il s'est
évadé par hélicoptère de la prison de
réau en seine-et-marne le premier
ministre veut des réponses edouard
philippe qui doit faire passer un grand
oral cette semaine à ses ministres le
chef du gouvernement va les recevoir
pour évaluer à leur action c'est la
deuxième fois que l'exercice a lieu
depuis le début du quinquennat
emmanuel macron lui est en afrique une
visite de trois jours le chef de l'état
est l'invité du sommet de
africaine le président qui enchaîne avec
le nigéria et puis donald trump se dit
prêt à travailler avec le nouveau chef
d'état mexicain le président américain
félicite son nouvel homologue andrés
manuel lopez obrador amelot et qui a été
élu hier c'est le premier président de
gauche de l'histoire récente du mexique
[Applaudissements]
ont parlé du mexique il affronte le
brésil en ce moment en 8e de finale du
mondial de foot en russie le score 0 à 0
après dix minutes de jeu à 22h la
belgique sera face au japon il ya le
danemark et surtout l'espagne ont été
éliminés aux tirs au but à chaque fois
la france elle jouera son quart de
finale vendredi à 18 heures ce sera sur
la première et face à l'uruguay en
karaté la saison 1 s'est conclu hier
avec la coupe de mayotte et pour sa
première saison complète au sein du
giron fédéral la discipline a fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour grandir le
nombre de licenciés a presque doublé les
karatékas maoré échange régulièrement
avec leurs homologues de la réunion une
délégation de notre il a d'ailleurs
participé à la coupe de mayotte une
ouverture indispensable pour mylène
carpa et grondin directrice de l'élite
academy et cadres techniques de la ligue
réunionnaise de karaté il ya des moments
qu'il faut gagner il ya des compétitions
en fait faut bien comprendre nous il
faut gagner et il ya des compétitions
comme celle de ce week-end où on est là
pour mettre en pratique ce qu'on a
appris ces derniers mois donc on n'est
plus dans l'apprentissage dans ça c'est
sur l'aspect sportif mais venir à
mayotte aussi sur le plan culturel sur
le plan de l'échangé extrêmement
important comme je vous dis on peut pas
rester chacun dans son coin à faire son
karaté le mieux pour progresser même
pour les jeunes en termes
d'épanouissement en termes d'insertion
par la suite le sport c'est un des
meilleurs outils est possible il faut se
rapprocher il faut venir la réunion il
faut venir à mayotte et partir dans ces
échanges la main mylène carpaye grondin
cadre technique de la ligue réunionnaise
de karaté interrogé par fahid swahili
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant lundi politique gaël le nantais
qui reçoit ce soir jean pierre marchau
secrétaire régional d'europe écologie
les verts on parlera notamment à des
paillotes l'info revient à 19h en télé
dès 5h demain matin en radio
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout doucement
[Musique]
oui
et
tél
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
aulas
salah
[Musique]
on a
il est 18h15 vous écoutez la première
vous avez bien raison surtout si vous
intéresser à la politique elle lundi
politique gagne le dantec
faut-il autoriser ou interdire des
restaurants sur les plages faut-il
autoriser ou interdire l'enlèvement a
déroché dans les shows et dans les
rivières pour construire une nouvelle
route du littoral faut-il adapter les
lois pour pouvoir construire un hôtel en
haut du volcan comment atteindre les
objectifs ambitieux de réduction de nos
déchets et de notre consommation
d'hydrocarbures
comment préserver notre exceptionnelle
biodiversité
l'écologie est bien le centre du débat
réunionnais et pourtant l'écologie
politique comme les partis politiques
traditionnels semblent avoir disparu
sous la vague macro nien sur laquelle
surfe nicolas hulot à moins qu'il ne
soit lui aussi emporté
nous demanderons notre invité quel
regard ils portent sur ses actualités
sur ce paradoxe jean pierre marchau
secrétaire régional d'europe écologie
les verts également conseiller municipal
à saint denis et conseiller
communautaire la cinor où il préside la
commission transports et déplacements et
donc l'invité 2e lundi politique sur la
première jusqu'à 19h30 mission que vous
pouvez suivre également en vidéo sur le
site internet
j'aime vraiment chaud bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
dans l'actualité d'abord il ya ce
conflit qui perdure donc sur les plages
de l'ouest des restaurants que ce soit
installé sur le sable avec une
autorisation temporaire autorisation que
la mairie n'a pas souhaité la mairie de
saint paul n'a pas n'a pas souhaité
renouveler
pas plus que l'état d'ailleurs qui avait
donné jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
pour au restaurant pour quitter les
lieux et remettre en état ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait comment est ce qu on
trouve l'équilibré entre la protection
de l'environnement et le développement
économique c'est ce que c'est ce que
disent et ses restaurants plage mois on
participe au développement économique
alors si je peux me permettre d'être un
peu familier je crois que c'est un
véritable foutoir ce dossier des
paillotes puisque comme vous ai dit
effectivement ça fait quand même des de
nombreuses années que les existait moi
j'ai connu il ya trente ans le co coupe
il s'appelait pas comme ça c'est une
petite france d'une petite paillote à
l'époque et puis on l'a vu grandir ses
installations avec souvent la complicité
des élus le silence est tacite des
autorités publiques du préfet tout
simplement
donc le fait que des riverains
contestent effectivement la présence de
ces deux c'est bayonne qui aujourd'hui
ont empiété sur la mer ce qui n'était
pas le cas les profs et sur la plage
c'est pas le cas à l'époque ça c'est une
bonne chose
maintenant nous sommes pas des moi j'ai
jamais été un ayatollah ni mes camarades
nous sommes pour effectivement rendre
quand on compatit une activité
économique légère interdit mon talent
donc la position officielle des amis des
verts de saint paul c'était le retrait
qui aurait dû être effectuée le cap
était fait pour des tas de raisons des
lourdeurs nitrates yvette cerader donc
souhaité la meilleure solution le
retrait de ses restaurants je vais pas
les citer tous mais là vous verrez
reculer de quelques mètres
plusieurs mètres à arriver à l'endroit
peu près où il y aller aujourd'hui des
bons sens les voitures les parkings des
riffauds il serait bien de faire partir
ses voitures pour faire en sorte que la
plage respire voilà donc moi je crois
que c'est important mais en sachant que
c'est comme tout petit aspect des
problèmes ce que tout le monde si les
réunionnais savent qui a eu de
nombreuses violations de la loi littoral
qui a des hôtels qui sont installés sur
le sur le sur le domaine maritime public
ce soit dans l'ouest mais aussi à saint
pierre donc il ya quand même beaucoup de
lobby à très actif qui ont
voilà donc il faudrait pas aujourd'hui
pénalisé cette modeste activité
économique même si certains ont exagéré
il faut trouver il faut trouver un
équilibre voilà ça va être compliqué
parce que maintenant la zone selon
laquelle il aurait pu reculer a été
déclarée inconstructible exactement
probablement par la dial dans l' enquête
publique en tout cas c'est ce qui
ressort là ça va être compliqué
maintenant alors d'autant plus compliqué
qu'il est question si bien compris de
piétonniser aussi l'axé donc tu vois
plus de voiture jouet c'est à dire des
gens qui étaient contre les paillotes
qui tout à coup s'aperçoivent que
beugnot thème pourra garer leur voiture
je dis non il faut si on veut vraiment
écologiser le littoral il faut si on
veut et radicale on supprime les
paillotes mon supprimer l'accès aux
voitures
il en ira un pied en marchant il ya de
grandes plages dans le sud-ouest qui qui
m'a pas de souris snel de naissance et
bien vous garez très très loin des
plages ou marcher pendant près de 30
minutes par les sur la plage personnes
euros chine c'est une idée conditions
pour protéger le littoral du sud ouest
qu'il valait mieux protégés de france il
ya des lois nationales qui pose les
limites vous parlez de la loi littoral
qui disent le droit un droit qui doit
s'appliquer partout et puis en ce moment
beaucoup d'agitation autour de la
question finalement de la
décentralisation même si c'est plus trop
le mot qu'on utilise aujourd'hui enfin
ça reste le quart du du sujet beaucoup
de revendications pour décider ici la
façon dont on doit appliquer les lois
derrière ces revendications il ya
peut-être parfois notamment de la part
de la région la volonté peut-être
d'échapper à certaines contraintes
environnementales
quel est votre regard vous sur sur ce
délicat sujet entre décentralisation et
finalement contournement de des
contraintes environnementales
je vois sur cathédrale voulais pas mener
effectivement la bio puisque on cite la
région tout le monde entende parler du
schéma d'aménagement régional qui est
d'ailleurs en ce moment en train d'être
de fait la région de tentations un bilan
et des ateliers à la mi parcours
donc ce schéma d'aménagement régional on
sait que la région aimerait le assouplir
les règles puisque pour l'instant pour
le modifier de sa passe en conseil
d'état c'est lourd assez complexe mais
on sait aussi qu'il y a je vais évoquer
quelques lobbys il ya des gens qui
aimeraient bien faire des constructions
notant dans le parc national house est
strictement interdite donc il faut
trouver un équilibre qui vient blanc ou
en plus il y aura des adaptations mais
ça ça me choque pas mais il faut pas que
ce soit la porte ouverte effectivement
une activité économique dont on sent
qu'elle pourrait être débridé
on a vu ce qui s'est passé sur le
littoral on a commencé par de petites
installations puis c'est devenu ce que
c'est devenu et donc moi je suis
extrêmement méfiant sur cette volonté
certains acteurs de dire assoupli son
intérêt de menton ayons un schéma
d'aménagement comme en corse où
effectivement la décision et locales
et on voit ce que cafés l'aménagement et
la spéculation mais oubliant qu'en corse
il ya des dangers réels donc presque en
même temps ça serait pas mieux de
décider ici comment est-ce qu'on protège
notre environnement plutôt que par
emilie ballon ça vous n'avez pas le
droit savait pas alors moi je suis bien
d'accord que ça serait bien d'avoir
effectivement des règles locales émises
ce projet avec plusieurs acteurs pas
simplement le conseil régional qui
serait soumis à une majorité politique
mais avec plusieurs acteurs c'est-à-dire
le représentant du préfet de
représentants d'associations
environnementales pour les doigts au
chapitre patiemment voix consultative
pour trouver un équilibre et mes chances
que tous les acteurs même
environnementales sont soucieuses aussi
bien le tueur il faut trouver une
solution et c'est vrai que comme on
parle beaucoup à la réunion de choisir
niveau d'autonomie sao tomé dans les
quelques débats c'est à dire de prendre
des décisions pour un développement
qu'on me dit endogène dire la seule
susanne développement endogène ces
frictions coup soyons maîtres de notre
destin en pour l'instant la réunion
n'est pas maître de son destin sur des
tas de plans on en reparlera peut-être
tout à l'heure mais effectivement voilà
donc c'est ce sont des problèmes
complexes mais moi je tranche pas d'un
côté en disant on touche pas en national
parce qu'on voit bien effectivement sur
par exemple sur le débat sur le partage
ionale cette situation complexe
ce n'est pas non plus laissons libre
cours aux décisions politiques d'une
collectivité quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs quelle que soit la majorité
qui anime cette cette collectivité parce
qu'effectivement c'est la puissance des
lobbys donc peut-être je parlerai tout à
l'heure et qu'ils font souvent ce qu'ils
veulent je le disais à notre industrie a
beaucoup de sujets sains qui concerne
l'écologie quand l'actualité
réunionnaise dans l'actualité en général
il est vrai qu'ici on en parle on en
parle beaucoup les sujets récurrents
notamment autour de la question des
matériaux nécessaires à la construction
de la nouvelle route du littoral sujet
récurrent s'il en est depuis depuis
quelques années maintenant et nouvelle
enquête publique est en cours concernant
le projet de carrière de bois blancs une
troisième consultation dans un contexte
assez floue puisque la révision du
schéma départemental des carrières a été
retoqué par le tribunal administratif de
bordeaux la région le groupement l'état
sont ils en train de s'acharner à
vouloir ouvrir cette carrière ou est ce
que ce sont des opposants qui mettent
des bâtons dans les roues d'un projet
qui de toute façon on va voir le jour
non je crois que c'est un projet halo
reach geralt leurs eaux du littoral
pendant qu'ils étaient mal mal ficelé il
faut être clair ça a été bien ficelé on
aurait la région et des manifs aurait pu
même si évident et raucourt et se prêter
les carrières depuis 3 4 ans qui était
prévu dès 2014
ce n'est pas le cas pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement le on n'a pas un refus
il n'a pas voulu modifier le schéma des
carrières de 2010
on l'a simplement révisé c'était
beaucoup moins long et moins lourds à
faire et à méan sauf que là encore on
est passé outre voilà une autorité
environnementaux voilà donc la
conductrice d'appel de bordeaux a chanté
le schéma d'un schéma départemental des
carrières pour on revient actuellement
celui de 2010 en coton pour moi
aujourd'hui je vois pas comment
légalement pour exploiter des carrières
qui sont pas qui était pas dans ce
schéma des forêts ans mais des sourires
commencé les démarches assez longue
effectivement d'où le retard qui sera
pris parce qu'actuellement même si la
région la région le préfet veut passer
en force sur bois blancs et s'exposaient
des retours qui pourrait être gagnée
parce que effectivement la décision
d'accorder m c'était apple produit très
clair alors donc là l'autre élément qui
est extrêmement gênant c'est que
actuellement vous savez peut-être que
vous si parler de ça en attendant
d'avoir des roches massives qu'on n'est
pas près d'avoir quand même pas ce qu'il
faut comme que les autorisations se
fasse et sont pas faites en exploite des
fameuses an dernier vous vous étiez
exprimé pour dire à l'occasion des des
intempéries de ce début d'année en
disant attention et les glissements de
terrain les coulées de boue sont aussi
et peut-être dû à l'enlèvement des
andains dans les champs et donc il ya ça
et puis à ce projet aussi d'enlever des
rochettes dans des lits de rivières
éventuellement qui a été évoqué ce sont
deux options qui vous semble vous
dangereuse alors pour tous les ans des
infections provenait le seul parti à 7
exprimé là dessus en disant vu des
dégâts extraordinaires provoquées par de
petits cyclone berg ita et fakir avec
des glissements de terrain destruction
de routes et basculement dans la boue
dans les wagons on a mis en cause le
repos les ventes en hausse et j'ai
rencontré la dea ya pas très longtemps
que 3 millions de tonnes 3 millions de
tonnes c'est énorme dans d'un an ont été
prélevés
à ce moment les uns superficiel dans
l'historique mais les indiens on pouvait
creuser le sol
aujourd'hui les transporteurs veulent
aller plus loin puisque je crois que
l'un des principaux
parle encore d'un gisement de demi heure
c'est faux le gisement exploitable ses
2,3 millions 2 l'a déjà dit on pouvait
trouver autres tirent encore quelques
centaines ou milliers mais si on le fait
effectivement le risque c'est de voir
les meilleures terres agricoles partir
dans la gombe disparaître ça serait
contre l'intérêt qu'elle a eu des études
d'impact on imagine avant d'autorisation
des fouilles les tendances mais au début
on pensait qu'on aurait à prélever que
les andains historique les deux
protocoles le premier qui portait sur
les andains historique elle était rien
d'un premier répit rage parce qu'on
pensait qu'on allait avoir les fameuses
carrières en les cas rien ne venant pas
depuis trois ans on fait deux ans on
fait deux mandats
et vous parlez des roches dans les
rivières en fait les a jamais eu de
carrière de roche massive à la réunion
il ya que des carrières alluvionnaires
consiste à prendre son camion allez dans
l'est des rivières est prélevé le
matériau mais on s'est effacé pour moi
qui le dit c'est le brgm il ya plusieurs
rapports qui disent qu'ils attention il
ya un épuisement de la ressource
alluvionnaires et donc il ya plusieurs
années déjà
berget me disait il faudra certainement
ouvrir des carrières de roches massives
alors qu'à l'époque on parlait pas lors
du littoral donc je veux dire en plus la
route du littoral
mais pourquoi il faudra certainement des
carrières de roches massives peut-être
pas les méga carrière dont tu as besoin
du littoral mais parce que tout
simplement la besoin de matériaux pour
qu'on se le dise écoles des hôpitaux etc
et comme la ressource alluvionnaires des
rivières les verts voie d'épuisement
puis elle pourrait elle aussi avoir des
impacts environnementaux
l'idéal c'est d'arriver à trouver les
carrières mai
certaines carrières de roches massives
pour pouvoir alimenter ce marché
puisqu'il je répète pas couleur ou du
toit la france est donc très compliqué
et la route du littoral le chantier
assure compliqué si je puis dire
la problématique des matériaux parce que
si elle domaine des carrières de roches
massives
le coût d'exploitation est beaucoup plus
élevé je crois c'est deux ou trois fois
plus élevé que ce que la carrière du
jeune r donc c'est à dire que les
matériaux lancement pour la route du
littoral mais aussi pour les hôtels les
échos les hôtels les hôpitaux les écoles
etc vont renchérir le berger dans ses
complices multiplié là aussi le prix de
matériaux par deux ou trois donc il ya
cette problématique aulas et je pense
que ce chantier n'a pas hélas arranger
la chose en la matière la solution
maintenant c'est quoi nous on préconise
la solution s'est rallié ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut être objectif
autant 2015 et une élection qui a été
perdu mais si elle n'avait pas été perdu
on aurait pu arrêter chantier
aujourd'hui c'est plus possible à le
viaduc en train de se construire ça
certainement achevée dans un an un an et
demi donc l'idéal le moins impactant
c'est la solution préconisée par la
srepen de tout viaduc la semaine c'est
le l'association de langlade qui associe
à france nature environnement tout via
du que ça c'est pas très joli c'est même
très moche assez horrible c'est
scandaleux même sur un plan du
patrimoine historique et je vais souvent
les rendre jaloux j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi les réunionnais sont
s'ils négligent parce que les rendent
jaloux c'est un lieu sacré comme
l'histoire lyonnaise il y avait un
ponton accoster les les engagés indiens
100000 engagés sont venus par cet
endroit il été mis en quarantaine
il y avait à l'époque tout un dispositif
bien aujourd'hui ce cet endroit
l'endroit où arrivait les
allez les engagés dont une grande partie
au vu des réunionnais sont les
descendants eh bien il est sous le béton
aujourd'hui je trouve ça tout à fait
anormal et choquant est malheureux mais
enfin bon
le fait est que ça s'est construit et
donc là la meilleure solution serait
soit ce tout viaduc soit une fois que la
solution préconisée par l'association
atr qui préconise pour la partie entre
la grande chaloupe et la possession
il ya dans les falaises à pic des
protections en béton donc je pense que
tactiquement c'est possible ça c'est
encore moins cher et ça éviterait de par
contre ça le gros problème que ça
poserait la région ce qu'elle n'aurait
plus à proposer le le pactole du
transport des roches facile parce que
c'est c'est bien ça le l'enjeu c'est à
dire que que soit le transport dandin
actuellement rapporte qu'un beaucoup
dans le champ des gens qui sont ce
qu'ils sont
tu as inventé une profession le train
l'invention ces transporteurs dans d'un
syndicat l'avion qui aime courir j'en
suis et demain si les roches massives
sont extraites dans une carrière qui a
plus de 30 km et bien on sait que le
transport du matériau le coup de métal
cool on va coûter 2 va être multiplié
par deux donc il ya des gens est ce
qu'ils vont dire est ce qu'il ya des
carrache massive mais le plus loin
possible de la la route du littoral dont
bois blanc par exemple ou dioré mais pas
pas ou lataniers et pas de carrière de
la montagne qui sont à moins de 30 km
jean pierre marchau à propos de nrl vous
avez souvent dit que le chantier était
symbole d'une politique du tout voiture
à la réunion si vous avez l'occasion le
dire ici d'ailleurs leur lors d'un débat
sur le sujet la solution aux
embouteillages la réunion passe par le
développement des transports en commun
évidemment vous êtes en charge de ces
questions à la mairie de saint denis à
la cinor on a le sentiment que ça
n'avance pas très vite que le syndicat
mixte des transports est un peu en panne
si j'ose dire avec un syndicat qui est
présidée par alizée quel bois qui c'est
qui se retrouve en minorité sur sur un
sujet de nos billetterie unique je crois
où est-ce que ça coince là alors pour
dire quelques mots là dessus même si
c'est un problème interne effectivement
bien comme il est paru dans la presse en
tout cas on est au courant effectivement
le moi j'estime que le cimetière le
syndicat mixte des transports de la
réunion est toujours dû empanner
paralysé
parce que ne se syndiquer à porter un
projet de billettique qui se révèle le
montage d'akissi seule façon d'acquérir
ce ce dispositif qui coûte 17 millions
10,7 millions d'euros ce qui est pas mal
même si la mutualisation des
collectivités pouvaient bénéficier de
subventions et ferez baisser le pied à
10 millions pour les collectivités le
problème c'est la civis a déjà son
équipement donc il faudrait que les
nouveaux équipements s'accordent
actualise la civis mais le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui à de nombreuses
collectivités qui ont déjà développé que
ce quoi la cirest que ce soit le car
jaune demain si ta liste pour la cinor
déploie une ce qu'on appelle une
politique légère donc ça ça fait pas
rater jardon dans ce dispositif qui qui
coûterait donc plus des millions mais 17
si jamais une collectivité s'en retire
parce qu'elle veut pas payer beaucoup
avancé que les rues le goût l'activité
on est contrainte budgétaire donc s'il a
une qui sortirent 10 pouces moi ce que
je dis souvent indique seulement
attention alix si une connexion n'est
pas sûr qu'une collectivité n'entre pas
dans le processus est ce qu'on l'a on
surtout avec un marché très 17 millions
et qui va dépenser 7 millions donc je
vis un peu paralysé on essaie de trouver
une solution il ya eu un vote
effectivement conclu 10 30 avril où le
président était totalement isolé cette
question depuis sa part lancé sap
avançait donc on essaie de trouver une
solution avec d'une part il ya deux
problèmes d'abord sortir de ce fameux
dossier qu'on appelle le ce tir le
dossier du style systèmes de transport
intelligents de la réunion sans qu'ils
ne cassent pour le pour les cimetières
parce que si au classement
la lente reprise qui attributaire du
marché fait un recours effectivement il
y aurait la caisse financière précepteur
donc donc pour les collectivités
donc nous non plus encore est le
problème c'est qu'ils te casse puisque
le marché n'ont pas été notifiés me dise
ont déjà réglé ce problème on l'a fait
le 10 au 11 avril
souhaitons que le président suivre une
autre préconisation qu'on arrête qu'on
écarte ce dossier ensuite et a été élu
président donc c'est un vote des lieux
je le respecte
dans ce cas là je veux dire il ya le
bois et carton ce mets ton ennemi non ce
dossier qu'une puis la vie et mes tongs
ou travail parce qu'il ya beaucoup à
faire vous allez lire on attend quand
même que ça que ça avance sur sur sur ce
dossier du transport en commun on sait
que
l'entrée ouest et est de saint denis par
exemple reste très complètement
complètement bouché même si voilà on a
des projets vous l'occasion d'en parler
ici noté gilbert annette de téléphérique
on sait que ça va avancer mais mais il
faut à l'ensemble voilà comme une fois
l'ensemble télé fric tout seul ça sert à
pas grand chose au fond un ciné
particulier sur sur un réseau
ferroviaire
demain j'espère alors pas le réseau
ferroviaire de la région le fameux
réseau réseau régional transport d'idées
le rpg qui parle on n'irait pas c'est
parce qu'ils croient pas assez que tout
simplement il faut d'abord payer la
route du littoral et les points confie
déjà l'évaluation qui de fait par la
région du rtg c'est quand même 4
milliards 5 g pas où est ce qu'on va les
trouver pour l'instant je ne pense pas
je sais pas si le gouvernement fait
l'état est prêt à financer l'homme
le monorail didier robert mais il ya un
projet à la haute et seo et on travaille
aussi même c'est pas tout à fait
officielle donc j'en parle pas trop
parce que je serais le président gérald
maillot on parlait un projet de tramway
notamment pour aider ses poulains de
l'entrée ouest qui répondu de l'aéroport
jusqu'à saint-denis pourquoi parce que
la question des reports étaient
essentielles les études montrent que
l'orne à peu près deux millions trois
touristes qui arrivent en 2030 on aura
plus de 3 millions de touristes sur les
calculs montrent l'aspect on espère mais
quelques montrent surtout que 6 à 3
millions et connaît toujours un
automobile on ne pourra plus accéder ni
sortir l'aéroport aux heures de pointe
donc et même à mon oreille ne pourrait
peut-être pas absorber les oublie
tellement un tramway alors dont
éventuellement un travaux est ramollie
par contre 8 2 2 de l'aéroport à voile
avec 5100 voilà en reprenant les
impatients qui pourrait s'articuler avec
un projet du tc au alors le thé sol il
serait toujours à la possession
donc lui on le ferait descendre dans une
hypothèse les visages se faire descendre
là où il pourrait se connecter deux
maintenant plusieurs années on va dire
là où il y aura un transport peut-être
régional de transport guidé
même si aujourd'hui c'est pas la
priorité parce qu'en fait les et du
transport montre que 90 % des placements
des réunionnais se font à l'intérieur
territoire c'est-à-dire la cinor la
casud traiter ses eaux il ya peu de
déplacements inter régionale d'accord
donc ce qui veut dire que c'est
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui la priorité
absolue d'avoir un transport ferroviaire
qui ré 2
de passe alors du mondial en tout cas
qu'ils voient qu'ils feraient tout
l'autre de l'île pour l'instant c'est
pas vraiment la priorité
sahnouni est confronté à ce moment là
vous avez raison l'entrée ouest pour que
la route un jour c'est finalement
s'achever et l'entrée est qui elle est
et il est encore pire en situation
encore pire même s'il ya moins de danger
en tout cas les gens perdent désormais
des heures dans les embouteillages à
l'entrée
autre sujet qui touche toujours
l'environnement et qui est qui qui
intéresse toute la région et donc vous
jean pierre marchau parce que l'on
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
régional d'europe écologie les verts
étant qu'il ya bien écologie dans le
monde votre parti on voit fleurir sur
nos murs de grandes affiches qui doit
vous coûter très cher par ailleurs
certaines disent sur fond de décharge de
l'enfouissement de nos déchets est
intenable
elle a sous-entendu faut construire des
uv eu deux incinérateurs enfin on
suppose que c'est ça qui est derrière et
d'autres affiches qui disent
l'incinération c'est absolument
insupportable sur fond de fumée noire
acquis qu'ils vont nous envahir
est-ce qu'on a affaire là une bataille
d'ego pour parler clair entre didier
robert et michel fontaine qui qui sont
sur des projets différents qui défendent
chacun une option parce qu'on a affaire
à une histoire de gros sous aussi entre
il y va d'un côté albi au mas de l'autre
comment est ce que on doit lire cette
affaire moi je ne suis pas dans le
cerveau de didier robert mais quand je
vois infections que la région faisait
grandes affiches n'êtes pas 3 disant non
aux incinérateurs finalement ça me fait
doucement rigoler parce qu'on disait
depuis 20 ans oui alors que la région a
pas toujours eu cette que l'on
compterait et puis on était vraiment
isolé enfin on était une poignée d'écolo
à dire non et sénateurs a expliqué
longuement pourquoi tu étais aujourd'hui
que la région le fasse c'est très bien
maintenant il faudrait pas que ce soit
effectivement une instrumentalisation du
problème des déchets parce qu'on a
souffert beaucoup à la réunion depuis un
temps de l'instrumentalisation des
poèmes des déchets qu'on n'a jamais
résolu
alors c'est vrai que didier roux a
hérité d'un dossier dans lequel nassimah
dindar pour la nommer puisque c'était le
département géré c'était le gros dossier
qu'avec à la bergère au département il
faut bien le reconnaître
en une quinzaine d'années elle pas
réussi à sortir le seul projet réglant
la question des déchets donc le comble a
dit la région hérité du problème le en
début d'année on va dire le le voyant de
région a fait son coming out il s'est
déclaré kolo finalement dix ans brosse
du jeu contre les incinérateurs donc
l'air lorsqu'il faut savoir c'est que
normalement la région va publier un plan
visant à les dénicher
ce plan là sera donc le plan
départemental pour la remplacer l'ancien
plan aujourd'hui qui fut pas encore fois
pour l'instant mais si demain ce plan
régional je suppose qu elle perde à
traduire la volonté de dire robert de ne
pas faire d'incinérateur sera posée afin
de pointer ce plan est opposable
opposable aux collectivités qui
concrètement elles bâtissent et puisque
la région est fait de la stratégie et
les collectivités que ce soit la cinor
et la cirest et la suffisance udf on met
en place des visites des unités de
traitement dont s'est effectivement di
leva le syndicat demi des déchets reste
à voir si ce projet sera compatible avec
le plan régional ça pose alors est ce
qu'il ya derrière une bataille politique
certainement bien entendu on se doute y
bagarre politique ce que je dirais c'est
quand j'écoutais longuement et
attentivement didier robert
j'ai trouvé que son hôte en effectuant
une cohérence finalement à faire une
simulateur pourquoi pas mais moi je
compte c'est trop voyant cela mais j'ai
pas compris ce que disait le 2 0 mais
quand il disait les déchets ultimes on
va aller brûler dans les chaudières de
tabula oui ça reste une incinération
si ces déchets ultimes s'ils se garent
du plastique etc je vois pas trop lui
n'a pas parlé des csr on peut dire
effectivement après tout sydney où il va
produire du csr pourquoi pas pressé src
compétition combustibles solides de
récupération où on fait des sortes de
boules et de voilà quelqu'un calorifuge
pour les mettre dans les poches en
complément de la bagasse ou du charbon
pourquoi pas ça une certaine qu'on
dirait cohérence mais quand on dit aux
verts dit non j'ai pas d'incinérateur
mais en fait ils finiront peut-être
brûlé dans les cheveux ras le bol d'air
frais qui m'explique comment parce que
pour l'instant je comprends pas d'accord
donc on attend
en attendant sécher mais enfin pour
l'instant vous avez raison il ya une
bagarre par jamais autant les politiques
de droite jacques fontaine dire aucun ne
se sont exprimées tant sur les déchets
de manière aussi spectaculaire mais ne
soyons pas dupes attendant d'en savoir
plus avec ce plan régional le plan zéro
déchet 2030 vous y croyez alors 2030 non
zéro déchet oui c'est notre objectif
d'arriver au bureau des schémas 1-0
déchets ça demande une planification sûr
20 25 ans avec d une organisation avec
des aides importantes en termes
financiers surtout avec des des
sanctions c'est san francisco où le la
ville san francisco que je crois 858
d'habitants et n'était pas encore au
zéro déchet elle travaille depuis de
nombreuses années elle s'y dirigent
progressivement je reconnais 180% de
récupération de recyclage mais il ya eu
des sanctions il étapes difficiles où on
a des sanctions financières étaient
rendus à la réunion il ya là dedans pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de sanctions ça
n'existe pas donc c'est un travail aussi
devenir de d'acceptation par la
population de prendre en charge ce zéro
déchet et peut-être que certains
diraient non vaut mieux finalement une
usine où je jette un bruit n'importe
quoi le danger là quand on brûle des
déchets le donjon le voir métropole
visiter incinérateur vous riez ambaud du
bois du plastique comme pour eux de tout
voilà la seule la poule problème il est
donc zéro déchet tonnes nobles objectifs
encore faut-il le tenir se donner les
moyens d'y arriver quand je dis des
moyens c'est pas simplement financiers
il ya l'aspect financier mais si le
moyen d'organisation d'une politique
avec peut-être une agence d'une échelle
réunion voilà un observatoire des
déchets quand on parle de déchets
évidemment puisqu'on a dit s'il s'agit
de brûler il s'agit aussi de fabriquer
de l'énergie avec et ça nous amène sur
sur le sujet l'autre sujet défendue
aujourd'hui par la région on va vers du
sens pour son énergie renouvelable là
encore on se dit oui le discours est
plaisant quand on a comme une impression
de déjà vu
on a entendu ça depuis longtemps depuis
des années est ce que ça avance vraiment
est ce que vous y croyez
alors ça n'avance pas si on regarde les
chiffres produits par la région par le
c'est l'énergie qui que j'ai consultés
avant tout dire justement pour les
meules et armero et on peut dire sert qu
en fait puisque il faut savoir que là ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon technique
le taux de pénétration des énergies
renouvelables est en train de baisser il
était de 47% dans la production
électrique en 2000 aujourd'hui des
tomber à 34% il a perdu 13 points
on voit que la production ait l'air
électrique actuellement à 66% dépendante
du charbon et du fioul
on voit aussi que notre ce qu'on appelle
notre taux de dépendance énergétique est
passé de 84% 82 97 % en 2000 aujourd'hui
presque 80 7%
c'est à dire que on est en train de
s'éloigner de plus en plus je parlais
pas d'électricité de l'énergie
l'indépendance énergétique l'autonomie
énergétique c'est-à-dire de l'objectif
du projet fameux projet gerri c'est très
compliqué à mettre en place mais là le
problème c'est qu'on entraîne non pas
d'avancées mais de reculer donc on peut
effectivement je ne crois pas dire
toujours autonomie énergétique et héra
ménard il faut regarder la réalité la
réalité elle est là la réalité c'est que
nous reculons que le photovoltaïque ne
progresse pas énormément et surtout que
nous n'avons pas ces fameuses énergies
pérenne et non pas intermittentes comme
le lait au liège neuf doigts ou le
soleil il faut des énergies behren donc
à deux grands axes ce que je vais
développer je me le rappeler marocain
pulsative créer un pool énergétique
autour d'eux des grands des énergies
d'énergie géothermique nous avons la
même structure il ya certains ont des
ressources de chaleur sous le sens il
faut les faire d'abord les chercher pour
lens des expos dépit de toutes les
ressources liées à l'énergie des mers
que ce soit en surface en profondeur et
et herat il y avait un projet qu'on a
perdu à la réunion nous avons été
peut-être dans la voie de l'innovation
mais aujourd'hui je jour il faut bien
reconnaître on n'avance pas énormément
et or c'est la clé l'autonomie
énergétique entre peut-être pas
l'autonomie entre elles le déclin de la
dépendance énergétique qui pourrait être
amorcé ce qu'ils ont exploité des
énergies pérenne géothermique ou
énergie houlomotrice ondes et des mères
nous permettrait aujourd'hui d'être plus
sereins sur l'autre à venir si on n'a
pas cette indépendance énergétique
eh bien on va dépendre l'indépendance en
extérieur mais aussi des crises
internationales d'ici demain elle se
déclenche au tour du pétrole par exemple
avec la peut-être demain les problèmes
dit avec l'iran où on sentirait fait
grandement ce d'autant plus grandement
peut tout déplacement à la réunion ii
pour le travail pour les matériaux le
marché se fait par la route vers des
camions des voitures
donc si jamais effectivement ce cette
dépendance était affecté par une crise
majeure on sentira ce moment-là kong m
sont fragiles on va faire une petite
pause musicale on va écouter marvin gaye
merci merci mais choisis par jean pierre
marchau pour cette émission écoutée via
des questions d'écologie on en reparle
après
wahaha
[Musique]
oh
ouais
blue sky
bon ami
[Musique]
en montagne
oissel leucémie
open
oh
on reste élégant
à
deschamps
[Musique]
dimanche m
oh
oui
et ce manque de poids
[Musique]
en plus angoissés
ne pas refaire son retard
[Musique]
à
marvin gaye mais si la ceni choisi par
notre invité jean-pierre marchau sait
pas forcément mais il est question
effectivement d'écologie dans cette
chanson
oui on pourrait penser que c'est une
chanson d'amour puisque c'est un
chanteur marvin gaye effectivement qui a
beaucoup parlé d'amour mellassine chance
en politique en fait qui extrait d'un
album politique let's get it hot dans
lequel il le dénonce la guerre du
vietnam et ses salades 1071 ya presque
50 ans il parle d'écologie de pollution
était à l'origine ans de bagne un petit
peu dans leur gîte et parce qu'ici de
dieu et c'est mon ski pas mon cas moi
mais en tout cas c'est bien d'arriver à
une prime prise de conscience et à 50
ans déjà bien avant le sommet de rio des
problèmes de problème soit je voulais
montrer un peu cet aspect de en plus sa
musique est très belle c'est le trio
magique lui quand il me fit d'elle et
ice à kyle donc ces voix là c'est un
genre de musique que j'aime beaucoup et
qui montrent qu'il ya derrière de un
contenu politique
oui c'est l'écologie politique
finalement ça date pas d'hier et
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'elle
entend malgré tout de régresser dans
l'opinion dans le discours est ce que
emmanuel macron a réussi à faire
disparaître l'écologie politique comme
il a fait disparaître quasiment le parti
socialiste et qui s'apprête de faire de
même avec les républicains effectivement
le ce qui s'est passé avec emmanuel
macron 1 a des effets dévastateurs sur
tous les partis politiques dont le nom
le nord effectivement avec le fait aussi
que l'écologie est entré un peu dans
tous les discours les ont parlé tout à
l'heure des incinérateurs les grandes
multinationales de l'incinération elle
maîtrise la rhétorique écolo qui fait
que moi j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens
qui consomment sénateurs ils vous
parlent le langage écolo metex
excellement excellemment donc voila nous
nous avons à combattre pour expliquer
d'autant plus des problèmes complexes
donc voilà il ya les échéances
électorales on se positionne et puis
surtout il faut qu'on soit pour de
propositions pas simplement nous
cantonner à dire non à ceux ci n'ont à
cela il faut faire des propositions et
puis le fait d expliquer aux lyonnais
c'est vrai qu'à la réunion la conscience
écolo et impôts lui tardive peut être
servi aussi à notre insularité
certainement mais moi je ne désespère
pas je dis il faut être patient il faut
travailler
nicolas hulot ido au gouvernement ça
pouvait paraître comme une chance pour
l'écologie
ou comme une trahison d'un représentant
de l'écologie quelle lecture vous en
faites vous aujourd'hui
moi je vais pas jeter la pierre il a eu
raison après tout de son point de vue
est allé au charbon comme on dit bon
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui le regrette
parce qu'effectivement sur la sphère du
glyphosate sur d'autres affaires
on voit on voit aujourd'hui qu'il ay n'a
pas gagné n'a pas gagné de bataille bon
il vous lui en voulez sur le glyphosate
alors pas d'avoir posé plus nerveuse je
jette pas la pierre à une personne je
pense que c'est il ya des lobbys
puissants il ya des gens qui ont pas
pris de position je fus juste un aparté
il ya quand même
j'étais un peu surpris de voir que les
sept députés réunionnais était absent
lors du vote en jeu bien calés ou deux
absents puisque on est loin mais cette
ça fait beaucoup
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de recruteurs
qui votent mais je trouve ça un peu
étrange voilà donc non je vais pas lui
jeter la pierre à lui mais nous sommes
dans une dynamique qu on est toujours
sur l'utilisation du langage écolo la
rhétorique écolo mais la réalité n'est
pas écolo du tout alors justement ce qui
nicolas blot quand il dit qu'il a obtenu
des moyens le maquereau l'inscription
dans le premier article de la
constitution de la protection de
l'environnement est ce que c'est du
certains disent et du du greenwashing
constitutionnel ou est ce qu'il ya
vraiment là une avancée possible
alors si c'est inscrit dans le projet
d'article lieu à la salle une importance
parce que ça permettra ensuite déployer
d'autres types de lois et de donner
force de loi à des dispositifs qui pour
l'instant sont non pas de son propre aux
abl voilà donc ça serait important
si c'est dans les cinq ans dans la
constitution de notre article n'a pas
d'intérêt je serai dans le 34
éventuellement dans l'article 1 ça
serait important parce que en termes
auger pas en train de monstration je
vous dis que je mettrais pas moi même
d'ailleurs
mais en termes c'est important parce
qu'on pourrait s'appuyer là dessus
ensuite pour déployer un arsenal
juridique qui serait contraignant et qui
pourrait s'opposer au lobby au lobby
économique
le livre bleu issue des assises a été
dévoilée la semaine dernière et définir
la feuille de route du gouvernement pour
les outre-mer pour les prochaines années
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous en
retenez alors il ya des menaces qui
pèsent sur
l'abattement de 30% sur les impôts sur
le revenu pour pour les outre-mer on a
parlé la sur rémunération qui fait
grincer qu'est ce que vous en retenez
vous de ce livre bleu alors il ya 200
pages qui vient de sortir encore détails
mais le détail les quelques éléments que
l'on a d'abord je veux qu'une chose que
annick girardin avait annoncé en
décembre 2010 est un fonds vert
notamment pour d'autres mais on joue on
ne trouve pas dans le livre benoît en
tout cas je n'ai pas lu suffisamment
attentivement je vois pas y a rien sur
la continuité territoriale qui est très
important pour l'instant c'est la région
qui paye cette continuité pour certains
réunionnais
donc je crois qu'elle a abordé mais pour
un public très très ciblée il revient
sur la vie chère et on arrive d'un
prochain qui haussera les 10 ans du
cospar et avec grande mobilisation à
laquelle j'ai participé sur la vie chère
aujourd'hui on voit que tout est retombé
qu'on est toujours dans la même
problématique de cette vie chère est ce
que effectivement vient d'apprendre
aujourd'hui est dévoilée par un de vos
confrères la presse écrite quotidienne
le quotidien pour le site est donc
visiblement effectivement il y aurait
l'intention d'utiliser le supprimer
pardon l'abattement 30% et même je crois
que le fond
la tva nous récupérables nos perçue est
récupérable qui est une forme de
subvention qui est importante quand pour
m de rayon c'est l'absence
d'investissements sauf ceux du public
effectivement mais donc il ya des
dispositifs qui permettait à peu
d'investissements aussi demain
effectivement heureux non là je dis
social on supprime cet abattement de 30%
déjà on va voir je pense que les
réactions se font 20 entendre un peu
partout là où ils existent mais il faut
savoir que premièrement ça va nous
toucher que les gens qui paient des
impôts et à la réunion je reconnais
moins de 30% des 35 37% de contribuables
assujettis à l'impôt qui paie qui met
l'impôt effectivement ça va toucher des
classes moyennes certainement
qui quoi qu'elles fassent et qu'ils
travaillent vivent à la réunion bien que
cet argent qui est économisé sur les un
poids le dépensent donc
moi j'ai pas de position a priori mais
je dis simplement comme nous avons des
handicaps structurels nous avons des
problèmes que je viens d'évoquer la vie
chère quand les territoriales etc
si demain en plus on supprime c'est une
partie de la population cet abattement
de 30%
on prend des risques extrêmement
important et surtout le gros scandale
session bien compris on veut financer
les projets du du pôle fameux fonds
exceptionnel d'intervention par par des
réunionnais pour les réunionnais qui
perdrait ses 30 % d'abattement peut-être
demain la subvention exceptionnelle
donc ce serait extrêmement signes
étaient convaincus que ni les
réunionnais dire les les autres
ultramarins n'accepteront tel tour de
passe-passe je note aussi je crois bien
peu sur le le plan de développement pour
la guyane ya pas grand chose sur le
livre bleu alors que les promesses qui
avaient été faites dont tout ça on est
en train de l'analyser
certainement que l'on parle un jour
prochain mais pour la fin c'est ce que
je notais et sur le concret je note
aussi que l'un des projets que site
emmanuel macron c'est la nouvelle route
du littoral donc j'ai pas si c'est
extrêmement aux vertueux un des sites et
un projet d'infrastructure qui coûtera
plus de 2 milliards qui favorise
d'automobiles
je me souviens quand nicolas sarkozy
même si ça a échoué quand ils venaient
en 2010 au moins a annoncé un plan
véhicules électriques qui n'a jamais
marché de l'or c'est pour ça il faut se
méfier l'iran annonce qui n'a pas trop
de sens l'économie carbone évidemment
mais on a l'habitude
il ya aussi les états généraux de
sarkozy il ya le plancher le fameux plan
gerry qui a fini c'est un pur scandale
dont il faut se méfier des effets
d'annoncé et de ce que ce qui sera
suivie mais il faut être vigilant
ce cette affaire effectivement qu'il
voudrait faire financer le développement
par les réunionnais eux mêmes dans
l'actualité politique
il ya aussi cette histoire de révision
constitutionnelle qui pourrait être
l'occasion de supprimer l'amendement
virapoullé europe ecologie les verts une
position tout ceci oui nous sommes pour
la suppression d'un navire a coulé
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ça nous ça
mais les réunionnais en est ce qu'on me
concerne ce dernier comme démineurs
incapables d'accéder à la majorité et de
prendre leurs décisions eux-mêmes donc
la première phase effectivement ce
déblocage institutionnels j'ai évoqué
d'énergie par exemple là si on veut
demain créer un pool énergétique
qui est capable de faire de la recherche
qui est capable ensuite de phares
exploitation qui est capable donc de
créer les instruments économiques qui
vont exploiter les énergies marines et
les énergies géothermiques pour aller au
delà du fameux photovoltaïque qui jamais
pour un réseau de près de l'autonomie
alors il faudra effectivement connaît
l'autonomie des capacités à produire des
lois locales tant qu'on le fait pas on
sera comme des mineures des enfants qui
dépendent de leurs seins de grand papa
de brême et de loin de papa macro je ne
sais pas on en sera là donc que là c'est
dur à comprendre comment un homme
politique aujourd'hui réunionnais ne
pourrait pas accepter la suppression du
de l'amendement virapoullé et c'est
pourtant le cas didier robert c'est le
cas des européens ce que je pensais à
lui justement quel regard vous portez
vous sur la politique des manuels
mcroberts pour parler encore de lui s'en
rapproche très clairement
gilbert annette avec qui vous travaillez
aussi comment est ce que vous voyez
cette politique en dehors des questions
strictement écologique sur sa position
politique économique sociale moi je fais
nous n'aimons pas le confusionnisme à
dire cécile raisons pour lesquelles nous
avons semble seul parti à ne pas avoir
participé assister au congrès fédéral le
parti socialiste de gauche c'est là sauf
nous pourquoi parce qu'on estime que la
confusion qui était entretenue entretenu
par certains élus socialistes mais entre
gilbert annette je l'avais dit à
l'époque un appel à voter g2 pour
emmanuel macron tout ça entretient une
confusion politique qui fait beaucoup de
dégâts on pourrait la population est
aujourd'hui beaucoup se positionne pour
être en argent pour l'éthique est en
marche dans de futures élections étaient
tellement ça ça les regarde la politique
effectivement de d'emmanuel macro on le
voit l est
les dents lors de l'état d'esprit de ce
qui était déjà qu'en été misés
l'économie c'est derrag de monter est-ce
qu'on lui tout réglementation règlement
toute réglementation qui est protectrice
d'un certain pour certains domaines et
offre un donc qui a tout un catalogue de
la loi et donc une loi des
règlementations il ya beaucoup de moi
comme ça et mais la société fait
ensemble fragile et notamment la réunion
on ad je crois que les agriculteurs des
des cultivateurs de canne à sucre par
exemple c'est un secteur extrêmement
fragile vous avez les mêmes des
transporteurs ils sont ceux de séoul
si demain il ya plus de rouge à
transporter ce cachet camions et on
s'aperçoit que la société n'a à son le
fragile et arrêtent déréglementé à tout
va
sans prendre en considération les
aspects effectivement les groupes
sociaux qui aujourd'hui sont certains
sont dans un déclin va dire économique
eh bien on arrive à créer beaucoup
d'exaspération et avoir cette de francs
scindé en deux entre les les antilles
macron et puis les pros macron qui sont
surtout ceux qui jugent de masse père
avoir l'étiquette qui vous permettra de
clore une petite minute un mot des
prochaines échéances électorales locales
avec qui et ce qu'europe écologie les
verts va pouvoir s'allier jean-alain
cadet a disparu est parti avec didier
robert au niveau national alliance avec
benoît hamon n'a rien finalement donné
vous allez faire comment je précise bien
que aux européennes europe écologie à
nos listes autonomes en lamé national
puisqu'il est évidemment sur les
élections locales mois la position que
je fais mon parti à laquelle je vais
travailler puisque ça sera pas avant
2020 dont on a aimé c'est de négocier
effectivement avec localement il n'y a
pas de d'émotion régional va pas dire
tel parti est meilleur qu'un autre
tout dépend des rapports de force mais
l'idéal effectivement et c'est pour ça
que je gentiment de lui sur notre
expérience à saint denis
c'est d'avoir si on estime qu'une
majorité peut se construire au port à
saint paul à saint pierre mais aussi
ailleurs à saint-andrew pas etc
je suis prêt tout examiner voir quelques
compositions quelles alliances on peut
faire l'objectif étant d'avoir des élus
mais surtout que ces élus soit dans une
majorité ce qu'on a fait à saint denis
on va renforcer ce protocole d'un
protocole d'accord qui nous permet à
nous d'imposer certaines idées et même
si on est minoritaire dans cette
majorité et demain d'avoir une
expérience
ce qui est nécessaire pour se développer
en politique merci beaucoup jean pierre
marchau d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
pour lundi politique dernier lundi vers
6 de la saison on se retrouvera bien sûr
à la rentrée demain un club de la presse
spéciale fin de saison également
reviendra sur les grandes actualités les
grandes lignes de l'actualité de ces
derniers mois dans 2010 en fout en
attendant c'est calypso rose
[Musique]
petit empire mal